imagine yourself with nothing more than
a pencil some paper and a desire to find
a formula for computing Pi there are
countless ways that you could approach
this but as a broad outline for the plot
line here you'll start by asking how
many lattice points of the plane sit
inside a big circle when I say lattice
Point what I mean is a point a on the
plane where A and B are both integers a
spot where the grid lines here cross if
you draw a circle centered at the origin
let's say with radius 10 how many
lattice points would you guess are
inside that
Circle well there's one lattice point
for each unit of area so the answer
should be approximately equal to the
area of the circle PK R 2 what we're
going to try to do is find a second way
to answer the same question how many
lattice points are inside the circle
because that can lead to another way to
express the area of a circle and hence
another way to express
Pi